this cockroach needs to get to Broadway
stat it's hopping on the owl
transferring to the nqr at Union Square
and arriving at its final destination
Times Square eventually your commute
becomes second nature you do it without
thinking and this cockroach is not
thinking either instead it's being
directed by a microchip in its backpack
[Music]
researchers at North Carolina State
University have found a way to bug a
cockroach by hacking its senses
researchers can remote control a roach
to go wherever they want but why would
they do this
I'm a terrible sport and I'm an
assistant professor in Electrical and
Computer Engineering Department at North
Carolina State University our idea is a
swarm of cyber roaches that carries
little microphones on their backpacks
and those backpacks has very sensitive
sensors and they're efficient radios
they form Radio Network and we help our
cyber roaches to decide in which
direction to go how does it work
cockroaches use their antennae to sense
and understand the environment around
them so when an antenna touches
something solid it sends an electrical
signal to their brain to turn in a
different direction
Alper Bozkurt harnesses this behavior by
attaching his own electrodes to the
roaches antennae under anesthesia these
electrodes stimulate the antenna to send
electrical signals to the brain and
allow Boz Kurt and his team to direct
the roach where to go these electrodes
are connected to the roaches backpack
which acts like an extension of the
roaches brain it consists of a battery a
microchip with a radio to communicate
with the controller and microphones to
triangulate sound you can actually try
this at home by purchasing a kit from
backyard brains to create your own cyber
roach cockroach not included hissing
cockroaches are available even in pet
stores and they are not pest insects
they are exotic pet insects from Mother
this is a chamber where we keep our
cockroaches and observe the behavior
cockroaches are amazing and they were
able to survive millions of years of
harsh environmental conditions and they
are good crawlers and they're good
climbers so in this chamber we try to
understand what does cockroaches do
during their day life and during their
night life so far this tech controls a
single roach but what about an intrusion
of cockroaches and what could you use
this intrusion for it was in 1999 I
joined the search and rescue efforts
after the earthquake in Turkey where
about 20,000 people lost their lives one
of the most critical questions is where
are the living surviving victims you
need to find those people in a short
amount of time time is very critical and
right now there is no technology out
there that can provide this with the
power of an intrusion he can send his
cyber roaches as first responders into
deadly environments to locate and rescue
potential survivors
for example during a search and rescue
mission they would release an intrusion
of cyber roaches to naturally roam the
search area as the roaches explore the
space they gathered data that is used to
create a 3d map of the environment if a
roach travels outside the search area
the computer will automatically
stimulate its antenna to direct it back
in once a roach detects the sounds of a
survivor beacons from fixed radio towers
would activate and locate the cyber
roach and thus the survivor
I love cockroaches some people may think
that they are very ugly but roaches may
also think that humans are ugly we had
very excited demonstrations in the
laboratory environment and we are ready
to bring this technology into
simulations of collapse buildings to
test it and find out what would be the
next level of challenges
these cyber roaches are just the first
step in cyborg insects DARPA is already
funding research into controlling the
flight of cyborg beetles and moths as
potential surveillance drones so watch
what you say because Sunday soon
Big Brother could be bugging your room
with an actual bug check out more
episodes of cyborg nation by subscribing
to the wired Channel